this is this is really bizarre what
happened in the last couple days
on this democrat caucus
which voted the democrat house caucus
which voted
218 to one in favor of a federal law
enshrining a right to abortion through
all
nine months of pregnancy the
congressional democrats abortion bill
would require that all 50 states allow
abortion after viability until birth if
a loan health care provider determines
the pregnancy poses a risk to the
parents to the pregnant patient's mental
health okay so there's a couple things
we have to talk about here now first off
i want to preface this all by saying
this is where i get
more pushback than on anything else from
my conservative and right leading
audience although i do have to say
without question it's always done
respectfully and thoughtfully
as you guys know in the book it's right
there it's right behind me
uh in don't burn this book i lay out my
position on on every political
issue of our time and the most difficult
section to write was about abortion uh
because it brings up existential issues
it brings up philosophical issues and
religious issues and scientific issues
and it brings up legal issues i mean
there's i found it to be the most
difficult to write it was the only it
was actually the only chapter in the
book that i asked for any help from it
from anyone and i had like a lot of
interesting conversations uh not only
with david but with candace owens and
with ben shapiro and dennis prager and i
talked to
several pro-choice people and i talked
to my sister i mean a whole bunch of
people my position on abortion is that i
acknowledge that when the sperm meets
the egg it's life i do i know it we're
in the midst of sega surrogacy right now
okay i know that when the sperm eats the
egg and then next thing you got a
blastocyst and you got an embryo it's
like it has to start somewhere it
doesn't just magically start when you
want it to start i i acknowledge that i
also acknowledge that in a pluralistic
society where people have all sorts of
beliefs and all sorts of religious views
and all of those things you want to give
the maximum amount of freedom to the
maximum amount of people i also don't
want the government making decisions for
people so that's why this is so complex
so i get i completely get the the
pro-life position which is conception
it's a life we have to protect life now
what the conservatives and the
right-leaning people don't do that well
on this is okay if you're gonna say
women you cannot get an abortion well
are you gonna help that woman during
those nine months of pregnancy are you
going to help that woman once the baby
is born and are you going to fund things
and everything else do you want the
government to do that because you
usually don't want the government to do
that so you're going to put that all on
private uh you know churches and temples
and things of that nature nonprofits
we don't really have that discussion
that often uh but i've discussed this on
the show you could watch some of my
previous interviews with ben shapiro and
dennis prager and other people that are
pro-life
what i've said to them
is that it's not that their arguments on
abortion have made me sort of more
i don't want to say anti-choice but more
pro-life
it's that the left has gone so bananas
with this
like they do with everything everything
without exception that that is what has
made me more pro-life so i used to say
20 weeks 20 weeks used to be the
position where you know doctors
basically said the fetus could feel pain
and i felt that that was a bridge too
far and then of course we can talk about
you know exemptions related to direct
health physical health of the mother
interestingly in this bill that the
democrats just passed 218 to one if you
heard the last sentence that i said
there it's now about posing a risk to
the pregnant patient's mental health
mental health yeah that's very different
than physical health and you only need
one health care provider to say it so
you literally could just find a nurse
you could find a friend who's a nurse
and you could be seven months pregnant
and be like ah i just am not in the mood
to do this anymore i'm kind of depressed
and it's like abortion time that's
literally what this will lead to so this
is this is just
messy all over the place okay it's messy
all over the place but as i've said to
shapiro and prager and some of my other
and glenn beck some of my other pro-life
friends it's that it's not that their
arguments are so convincing to me right
because i want the state out of the way
and i want people to be able to make
choices for themselves and and we can
discuss the life or death situation and
all that it's that the left goes so
crazy with it that it's like man i don't
want these people near any decision
related to a woman a man or a child or
anyone else if you think that
eight-month abortions are okay if you
think that five-month abortions are okay
like you need to be examined and again
we can talk about the exemptions we can
talk about when there's a true risk to
that woman's health we can talk about
when there is a horrific genetic disease
that that that child will never be able
to live a fully actualized life like we
could have all if we could if you guys
weren't so nuts about everything we
could honestly have those discussions
again that's what a healthy society
would do right is the same thing as the
border story we just covered in a
healthy society you would take a complex
topic we want to be open and pluralistic
and allow people to come here and we're
a nation of immigrants but we can't let
everybody in but you can't even have
that because you're racist and in this
case if you have the honest discussion
about
when does life begin what should a
society do do you want the government
making decisions for women blah blah
blah blah
and for the baby uh you know you're
either you either hate women or you hate
babies or the rest of it so we got to
get better at some of this stuff